[Music]
what up guys its goes on for anime
uproar we got a massive haul today
including a Code Geass package from
Japan this is probably gonna be the
biggest package opening of my life so
it's been a while since for our last
anime haul video it was back in December
so we've accumulated a bunch of stuff
since then especially since Orthodox
Christmas happen and we got a bunch of
presents
I gave Anna Mac anime related things
he gave me anime related things so we
got quite the anime / manga haul built
up just check this out
so I can barely lift it plus we got
those two boxes straight from Japan in
the back I'm excited Oh No
so as you guys just saw one of the
coolest things I got and I risked it
falling which was not a good idea it was
a Hadouken Suzumiya figurine how did he
sue you guys like one of my favorite
anime I love the movie as well a
disappearance of haruhi suzumiya and how
did he add the character is just awesome
and this figure is awesome just cuz it
catches like the dynamic character of
Hydra you know like she's she's like
never stationary she's always hyper so I
think this does a perfect job of just
capturing that essence that is ahead of
you and you know she's like a gun and
everything so that's kind of a big deal
as you can see the detail the
workmanship on this is insane now I see
why people buy so many of these
figurines and you know if we're gonna be
anime youtubers we should have some and
my figurines I mean I'm pretty sure it's
a prerequisite if you haven't already
watched a manga collection video then
check it out but I was missing pretty
much these Naruto mangas 7 and 11 so now
I got all the way from 1 to 13 which is
cool I mean I don't know if I'll ever
have all of them just cuz you know money
so if there is an arc of manga once the
13 volumes complete still working on it
but ever since I was a kid I loved
reading the art among guy knows what got
me into reading other manga so I have
not to thank for that
believe it and then we got this so whoa
this is literally every volume of attack
on Titan release thus far there's more
online chapters so I'm caught up on
those too but this is everything that
you haven't print so far so we got it
all
whoa let me put this down I'm not in
shape guys so the reason that we didn't
get 16 to 20 in this massive colossal
collection is because those other ones
haven't come out yet it's what we only
have the small ones but to be honest I
mean this is sick
and I got them beach for around like 50
or less dollars and I mean it's it's a
cool way to experience it for sure
because you have these awesome images
and I think it kind of portrays that
makes you feel like the characters
because the Titans are gigantic and this
book really emphasizes that with the
drawings like look at that that's cool
but at the same time at the pages are
like I didn't bother me too much but the
pages are a bit glossy and obviously
holding this while chilling on the couch
wasn't easy I guess heavy stuff though
so overall I feel like I do prefer the
small mangas and just so you can compare
this is about how much bigger it is so
it's a lot bigger guys so I'm really
glad that we finally got these it's
definitely one of the my favorite mangas
that I have in the collection now and
while I was reading it I was just
thinking again wow how this is it has
one of the strongest starts I've seen in
manga it also does not have that feeling
which I kind of got during the anime
where I felt like it dragged on a bit
you don't get that with the manga at
least I did it so with that being said
I'm very proud this purchased very
excited and thank Anna Marcus he
contributed to getting the last five
volumes for me for Christmas Serbian
Christmas so shout out the hand another
mug which is not technically mine but I
did buy it and buy a four Animax for
Christmas Nausicaa of the valley of the
wind I thought you know how we've been
all trying to get Anna Mac to read manga
well what better way than this
especially how much he loves Hayao
Miyazaki so if you guys can just go into
the comments right now and peer pressure
Anna Mac to get on those manga
immediately we got to work on this as a
community guys hashtag make Anna Mac
read manga
2017 and of course the art is beautiful
and we got a poster attached to it too
which I'll show you on the screen right
now and overall just awesome imagery
what you would expect from Miyazaki but
still it's beautiful to see and I can't
wait to read this one myself so this
contains a complete collection for this
manga which is pretty exciting all in
one place and again the papers actually
have the paper feel unlike the attack on
Titan colossal edition which have like
kind of glossy papers but it's
definitely heavy as well Anna Mac will
practice his muscles along with his
brain muscles while he reads this
masterpiece I can't put it back in
I also picked up this manga guys which
is called a girl on the floor and I was
originally thinking about getting it
because any old Asano also created this
solanine which is definitely one of my
favorite mangas of all time if not my
favorite it's a short piece just like
this one but man is it powerful so
definitely check this out if you haven't
already so I haven't had to read this
one yet but Aki dearest and cold
provider even recommended it so I'm like
okay I got to check it out since it's by
the author I love and also everyone's
saying it's good so let's check it out
don't want to cover up Naga their
respect and now we're gonna open the
packages you ready for this first we'll
open the top one so again these are both
packages are from Japan which is crazy
like I mean I couldn't imagine actually
getting [ __ ] from Japan before but
thanks to Amazon it's a reality
[Music]
Levi himself
alright I'm gonna take this out set it
up so you guys can see what it looks
like this is hard on looks this box will
be utterly useless
one hour later so we have head we have
the upper body we have the lower body we
have a rock and we have as is hoodie so
what does I call a shape CHF two hours
late they're having a really hard time
putting on them
sorry instructions on this thing
alright you guys might actually see me
break this in this video alright guys I
give up
so it's about as close as we got
actually putting it on okay I mean this
was cheaper to be fair but I've heard
good reviews so I don't know maybe I'm
deal I want does not put it on but yeah
it was only like I think 20 bucks all
the other ones work is it more expensive
like holy [ __ ] as you guys can see this
one's way way bigger than a jato anyone
so it's a bigger scale model Levi is
pretty short so it's it's funny
singham's little poem all around this
one looks amazing but the fact that I
can't put it like connect it is pretty
problematic so hopefully I'll be able to
figure that out and get back to you guys
stand out hard drum roll please
so you guys may remember that me and
Anna Mac had an epic epic Whitefoot wars
battle over calling clothes and cute he
made a quiz that I could get seven
possible code geass wife was herself and
I ended up getting it guess all odds it
was a hilarious video if you guys want
to watch it the link will be below but
as a trophy as a thing to remember my
great big tree by and I got this right
here box package from Japan let's open
her up and now with this one could be
much more careful
done with any other package I've ever
opened by the way guys for Colin best
waifu hit that like button for c2 best
waifu comment let's see who wins
there she is people and you guys tell us
my first unboxing video i'm so good at
it
[Music]
there it is people pull it or so now I
remember from the review this one is
actually detachable but I don't know if
I want to actually pull it and there we
are people and I actually like this call
it with hair let down a lot more than
when she has it up you know in general
cause awesome but I think her hairstyle
is better this way
and I think this is hands-down my
favorite call and close key figure eight
and here we are all set up greatest
trophy of all time
- forever prove that Collin close wookie
is in fact my waifu as everyone knew
goes on to waifu and on Animax dope
there it is guys that was the massive
haul and finally got my comment closely
trophy that I can lord over Anna back
forever for although we got a lot of
cool things I spent way too much money I
should I've and so it's gonna be three
square meals of this everyday
mmm chicken did you guys like this video
give me a thumbs up let me know what
your most prized anime-related
possession is in your collection in the
comments below and be sure to subscribe
for more anime content until next time
see you space cowboys okay now I
actually have to put away all this stuff
damn oh hey anima are you filming a
video without me yeah are you kidding me
are you kidding what do you want raphy
well stop rubbing this in my face we
will win this right here when will you
stop rubbing look can I just get out of
here man sick of your crap novel see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]